I'm joined today by Colin Moriarty who
is the creator of Colin's last stand you
can find him on YouTube and elsewhere a
lot of people in the audience actually
said Colin you should really talk to
Colin he's doing the rounds he is a
growing libertarian voice and will talk
to you about whether you agree with that
sort of identification so so maybe we
will start there I mean what how do you
identify politically as libertarian fair
I know your Twitter handle is no
taxation which reeks of libertarianism
to me but maybe that's just one issue
yeah the the no taxation reference is a
reference for the American Revolution
I'm obviously I don't believe I believe
in low taxation but it's really more
reference to no taxation without
representation and I went to school at
Northeastern University and your neck of
the woods I think and majored in
American history so that was really a
reference to that but I feel personally
that I'm a moderate conservative
specifically because I used to call
myself a libertarian before I really
started to think that I actually am NOT
a libertarian specifically with you know
some the role of government and all of
those kinds of things I'm more
libertarian on the social side so I
think it's more accurate to call myself
like a moderate conservative so have
your politics changed over time or has
this basically been your political
paradigm for I don't know as long as
you've paid attention to politics I
honestly feel like I've gotten more
liberal as I've gotten older which is
unusual they always say that you kind of
get more conservative as you get older
but yeah but they were wrong I mean I
don't know if you've looked into the
data on that what it's deceptive because
if you do a poll and segment it by age
groups at any given time the older age
groups will be more conservative than
the younger age groups but the reason
isn't because people become more
conservative as they age is because it's
because subsequent generations tend to
be more progressive and remain so during
their lives so that's a common you just
have to look into the data on that one
but yes you're right that's a common
phrase you hear thrown around yeah I
mean I I you know I would have thought
as a young you know when I became
politically cognizant in really middle
school or high school I was interested
in reading a bunch of different things
and I had friends that were reading more
like Marxist literature and stuff like
that which is interesting and then when
I got to college I kind of was more like
the first presidential election I voted
was 2004 and I voted for Bush and I
think I was a little bit more hardline
conservative not never really socially
but more in terms of foreign policy and
the like the role of government and as
I've gotten older maybe it's from ten
years living in San Francisco and now
I'm in Santa Monica I was kind of
softened a little bit on some of those
things but I honestly think that what
was missing with conservatism was
consistency in decency and that was kind
of a mainline for me to kind of chase
with my new project on what particular
issue do you feel or did you feel that
that decency was missing from
conservatism I think with social
policies I feel like you know a woman's
right to choose it seems to me
inherently a conservative principle
because it's a principle that says you
should leave the person alone to make
their own choices this is the same thing
with gay marriage I was a vociferous and
loud proponent of gay marriage when we
voted in 2008 here in California which
honestly are obviously failed so even
back then I felt like there is not a
decency in terms of the way we look at
others the way we treat others that a
transgender person has the right to live
a life unencumbered by government
interference even with the military that
a gay man has the right to marry another
gay man has the right to adopt a child I
feel like these are inherent principles
that actually line up with conservatism
if conservatism few means the government
has no you know or a limited role in
your life just like they have a limited
role in telling you you can't have a gun
they have a limited role in other ways I
just feel like there's a massive
inconsistency there and I don't like the
way and I still don't like the way that
republicanism and you know conservatism
treats you know the gay you know gay
groups and transgender groups and the
like see to me that just it sounds more
libertarian than than Republican and
maybe that's the issue your the argument
you're making which is that in reality
you represent what you think
conservatism of republicanism should be
but even the language you're using to me
sounds very very libertarian in a sense
I mean III researched a little bit some
of your foreign policy positions and to
give one if i if i misstating it
obviously please correct me it seems as
though you do tend to take more of a
Rand Paul approach on
foreign policy in terms of
non-interventionism except when the
United States is really clearly
indirectly threatened not meddling in
the affairs of other countries in the
sort of form of the policemen of the
United States is that true because that
at least over the last twenty years is
more aligned with libertarianism than
republicanism well I think that was one
of the major shifts and why I think that
it's a totally valid argument or
conversation to have about the
definition of libertarianism and my own
libertarianism and I'm sure will get
into other things that a better
decidedly not libertarian that I feel
but when I was in college we were
talking about Bush in my time at
Northeastern I was really for the war in
Iraq and and I really was for the war in
Afghanistan and kind of seeing through
our own lens the failure of those
conflicts particularly in Iraq and how
that kind of spread to a larger Middle
East unrest in my mind kind of showed me
that an interventionist foreign policy a
neoconservative foreign policy really
makes no sense and when you look back at
Vietnam and you look back at Korea and
you look at the you know these wars of
containment
for instance they didn't really solve
anything I don't think the United States
shouldn't get involved in anything that
doesn't necessarily affect it otherwise
we never we never really had a fight in
the European theater in World War two
and obviously that was the right thing
to do and we probably should have gotten
even gotten involved earlier yeah I mean
the counter to that would be we got
involved after Pearl Harbor most most
acutely and and that was when we got
involved because we were directly
attacked but we needed not not to sort
of rehash World War two history in full
right well that was the Pacific Theater
we could have taken the Japanese much
quicker remember that we inserted troops
in Africa and and and over in Italy 4243
yeah lend-lease was going on with Europe
but we could have focused on the Pacific
Theatre ended that way sooner probably
without nuclear bombs and ignored what
was going on in Europe and I don't think
that that was the right choice so I just
wanted to be clear yeah that there are
sometimes heinous and terrible things
that don't necessarily involve us sure
that we should still do something about
and I think obviously Nazi Germany was
one of those things but when we look at
Korea we look at Vietnam
I just see a lineage of these failed
Wars and these failed conflicts and
while I be I feel we should have the
most powerful military in the world the
greatest Arsenal of the best trained
soldiers we have all of that already it
doesn't mean we have to use it where are
you in terms
of this phrase that sometimes thrown
around and I asked this again because of
where we started on taxation the idea
that taxation is theft and I won't
qualify any further than that and sort
of turn it over to you is that a phrase
as I present it taxation is theft that
resonates with you or do you have
disagreements with that yeah I don't
necessarily agree with that statement I
think taxation to a certain degree is
the cost of living in a society and
that's obviously you know a common
phrase my dad used to use this term my
dad was very political and we've had a
lot of political conversations in my
life he says that taxation gets to a
point of being confiscatory in other
words you know there's a reasonable
level of Taxation and the taxation where
they basically are stealing from you or
taking too much and I think that's a
line worth drawing I think when you look
at your you know the funds that you make
gross every year let's say you make
$100,000 and then the government right
off the top takes 30% of that or so and
then the state government here in
California can take up to 13.3% of that
depending on your income bracket and
then you're paying sales tax sales tax
here in Santa Monica is 10% so you're
like as you're getting hammered over and
over again taxation does get out of
control and so I believe that we have to
pay some taxes I believe that there are
things we should be doing together and I
was actually against this recent tax
reform because it adds to the deficit
but I feel as if there's a reasonable
level of Taxation and an unreasonable
level of Taxation and I'm for making it
more reasonable I think it's far out of
the bounds of reason right now I mean
part for me and I'm curious to hear your
thought is there one side of it is in
the sort of abstract what level of
Taxation is or isn't reasonable and not
everybody will agree what that is but
that's sort of one side of the equation
the other side is what do you get for
the taxes that you pay is that something
you're also concerned about because
certainly if you're concerned about
military intervention the spending on
defense is pretty closely behind that
and then I'm in a position where I can
talk about reasonable and unreasonable
levels of taxation but it has to be in
the context of what are we getting for
that particularly when we look at what
some other countries get for the tax
rates that they have yes it is a huge
concern of mine about what we get out of
our
our tax money I've long been a proponent
of cutting military spending
significantly and I think that we could
probably afford across-the-board tax
cuts or I'm sorry spending cuts that can
then maybe trickle down towards and I
know the term trickle-down is loaded but
I mean trickle down towards the taxpayer
possible an audit of our spending these
I feel like there's a there's a lack of
concern with the American people and
certainly a lack of concern with our
representatives in the House and in the
Senate with how judiciously money is
spent and I think that we can cut waste
everywhere and even if we're cutting
waste only 10 million dollars here 50
million dollars there five million
dollars there that that does start to
add up that's real money and so I think
we should look at what we're getting out
of our tax spending and and I feel like
we don't really get very much I mean
that's my personal take but you know I'm
also in a privileged position
economically I grew up on a Long Island
in New York so I mean this is not a
depressed area so I know that it's it's
easy for me to say those kinds of things
but I think that we could probably cut
spending significantly I think the
government is too big but yeah although
I mean but are you making the argument
that that would be good economically
because at this point there's the you
know increasingly more and more economic
thinking that suggests that actually
even a focus on the debt is irrelevant
that that would be like the modern
monetary theory approach but even
stepping back from that even just
looking historically at the impact of
supply-side economics more broadly it's
really unclear that you can cut your way
to any kind of economic improvements
anyway yeah that might be true and in
fact that is a again a valid argument to
be had I'm not looking at it so much
from an economic benefit or an economic
deficit although that that matters I'm
really looking at it more in terms of
principle yeah and I don't like getting
too caught up on principle but the idea
that if you're giving a dollar to the
government shouldn't they spend that
dollar in the best way possible and if
they're not shouldn't you have really
serious questions about it regardless of
the economic benefit or the economic
deficit of say spending and its effect
on the larger economy which i think is a
different conversation entirely for me I
just feel like we should spend what is
reasonable we should get back what is
reasonable and anything apart from that
no matter how much we're spending or how
little we're spending should be
discussed because it is our money and
it's important that we spend it wisely
and as far as the debt and all those
kinds of things I know that there's this
argument a valid are
again I think I'm not an economist that
it doesn't really matter we can we can
continue to spend our way into debt but
I just don't believe that because if
it's true then why not just print five
trillion dollars a year you know that's
that's effectively what we do and really
we haven't had real that significant
inflation I mean I would encourage you
to check out the work of people like
stephanie kelton and paulina churn ava
and some of the other folks in modern
monetary theory because that's exactly
what they're saying which is we we do
that and depending on what we do it for
the idea that inflation gets completely
out of control it wouldn't happen it
hasn't happened but anyway that that may
be a conversation for another moment
before we move off of taxes do you agree
with me that taxation is theft is sort
of a losing libertarian argument in the
sense that I think that there are lots
of people who sort of identify either as
left or right who might be more drawn to
some of the reasonable libertarian ideas
that exist but when libertarians take
these absolutist views of taxation is
theft or even slavery I've heard that
they're sort of doing their own movement
to disservice do you agree or do you
disagree on that yeah I absolutely agree
I think that there's a cartoonish Ness
frankly to libertarianism to pig out
libertarianism that I I feel as a
turn-off because it's not pragmatic it's
not rooted in the 21st century Simon
rooted in the 20th century and as much
as I love iron Rand and as much as I
love you know the more philosophical or
high-level thought of a libertarian
utopia where the government isn't
involved and everyone lives a sort of
free life it just it's not the way it is
and in a society of three hundred twenty
five million people we have to have some
sort of social contract with each other
in terms of money in terms of spending
in terms of infrastructure etc that
makes sense for all of us so it doesn't
mean we have to have 25 cabinet level
positions or whatever in the future it
doesn't mean that we can't trim and cut
and make things more coherent and
smaller it but in terms of Taxation as
it's a funny thing to say but it really
doesn't make any sense because again
I'll say the taxation isn't theft until
it reaches a certain point at which
point I would say it's more confiscation
unless that all right let's pause there
we're speaking with Colin Moriarty
creator of Colin's last stand you can
find him on YouTube and elsewhere we
will pick up our conversation with him
tomorrow